[Music]
all right
hello everybody uh for those of you who
are
joining us uh from southeast asia
and oceania good morning
and those of you forum who are dialing
in from
all over the world we are very excited
to have you
and appreciate that you're joining us um
welcome to the stanford gsb alumni
panel uh featuring alumni from all over
the southeast asia region
um i will begin by sharing a little bit
of information
as we get going today and what you
should expect
so first of all my name is stephanie
wetland
and i'm one of the mba admissions
officers
at the stanford gsb and i'll be
moderating the panel
this morning during the next 55 minutes
or so
we'll have an opportunity to hear from
an
incredible group of alums who have taken
the time
to join you all today and share a little
bit about their perspective
and their experience at the gsb and also
to answer
any questions that you you might have
um i will kick off this session by
asking
some questions of the panel
and then i'm also going to take time to
moderate the panel
and ask questions that all of you
have for them so please be sure to
submit your questions
uh via the q a box all right
so for the sake of today's panel we are
focused on the southeast asia and
oceania
region but regardless of where you're
dialing in from
we know that you will be joining a great
community with over 66 countries
represented at the gsb who bring
together
different cultures beliefs ethnicities
there are really a plethora of
opportunities that
are available to you to really get
involved with the community
and we have over 50 student clubs and
organizations on campus
including the asia student business or
business student association
the gsb alumni network is truly global
we have over 60 alumni chapters
all over the world including over 45
outside the u.s and the class of 2021
is represented by 43 international
students
and 47 women just to give you an idea
all right so what i'd like to do is
start
by welcoming our alumni panelists
who have generously given their time
this morning to be with you
i'm going to turn it over to them to
have each of them
introduce themselves and i'm going to go
in order of how they appear
on the slide so uh atif you're up first
good morning my name is atib
from thailand and i did my duo degree
at stanford gsp class of 2014
and at the harvard kennedy school class
class of 2015
um currently i'm in energy industry
at ptt which is an energy conglomerate
of thailand
uh my role is to do bbd business
development
and international investment in power
business
so would be happy to answer any
questions
about gsb about
career after gsb energy in tech
or my prior experience before gsp which
is investment banking and
great energy you so much nice to meet
you all thanks
all right lizena sure
hello everybody um my name is lazina
rahman
i am mba class of 2010
and public policy class of 2011.
so i actually did a joint degree both
combined at stanford uh prior to
the gsb i was in investment banking
uh focused on general industrials
and at you know posted gsb i'm now at
ifc
and i focused on infrastructure
investment here in indonesia
and yes happy to talk about the joint
degree programs at the gsb
and in general international development
and
opportunities to look sort of beyond
conventional
um robles thanks very much
great thank you all right i'll turn it
over to bo
hi i'm bo i'm from thailand um prior to
gsb i i had a finance degree at thomas
university here in thailand
and then i worked in oil and gas and
business development
and then after the gsb now i'm working
with lauren corporation which is one of
the
biggest education company in thailand um
in the role of strategy and business
development
i'm happy to talk to you about anything
actually um and because
prior to the gsb i've never had an
experience living abroad before so if
anyone want to hear more about that
welcome
thank you all right we'll turn it over
to
nish
oh yeah gotta gotta take myself off mute
uh good evening everyone how's it going
uh my name is nish d'souza
uh mba class of 2010 uh so i was
classmates with lazina
pre gsb i was an engineer in the oil and
gas industry in in australia
uh working for woodside petroleum based
out of perth
so spent some time out at sea uh
managing
uh underwater projects for them and and
uh also overseeing the construction of
sub-sea equipment uh around the world
uh i currently am based in the
philippines been there for nearly nine
years
uh i recently started an e-commerce
venture with my wife who's also
incidentally
gsb class of 2011 focused on the
parenting space
uh and can currently also advise a
regional private equity firm called
creator on the philippines portfolio
so uh glad to meet everyone i'm happy to
talk about
uh both an australian southeast asian
perspective
of a pre gsp post gsb
uh spent time now across singapore
malaysia philippines and vietnam so
happy to talk about southeast asia more
broadly as well
great thank you all right
and we'll finish up with richie hi nice
to meet you all
uh i'm rachel um from the philippines at
class of 2020 so he said recent grad
uh i i took my undergrad at the
philippines and my pre-gsp background
was a mix of
investment management doing finance
focused on asia equities and
i was a teacher as well so i sort of
have a mix of an education background
now i'm a co-founder in a startup called
erudify we basically do education
finance and education services for both
indonesia
and the philippines so happy to chat
about that or anything
a recent gst grad can offer nice to meet
y'all
i'm wondering if any of you have been in
any other courses
that would be you know related to
whether um
you took any of the entrepreneurship
courses or design courses
that might be to share too
i took a class um called
brinjal capital and entrepreneurship um
it's a so so in this class we learn
a lot about how
startups in silicon valley
started the business and what are the
issues that they
face throughout the years and then we
got to meet a lot of
startup founders in the silicon valley
and one of our teachers is eric schmidt
who um come to class
every tuesday and then at the end of the
course we get to
form a group of like about four people
and
pitch us like build on a startup
um idea and then pitch to
um santa hue road um bc like they will
pair up
us us up with the descent like sandhill
road
um vc to be our advisor
and then they will help us kind of
formulate the business model further and
help with the pitch and stuff like that
and then at the end of the class we
everyone pitched to um
to the teachers and eric schmidt and one
of our classmates also got um
some investments from eric schmitz
because of this class so
in terms of the resources on
startups and i think mainly what i what
i see that is
very different from from other schools
is because of where we are located
because we're in the silicon valley
that's why
um we got to meet with a lot of people
in the area and
um it's it opens a lot of opportunities
and for the people and a lot of my
classmates that i
have seen they're trying to um connect
with the people
and and got some outcome of it
yeah thank you bo um it is helpful to
note that
you know stanford and silicon valley
essentially grew up together and we
often say that our
you know borders are virtually porous
and there's a lot of
um communication and just um
intersectionality between the two
so that people can get very involved
people come to campus
others get opportunities um to get
involved
so there's there's lots there available
to you you'll also notice we've put in
the chat
um a link so that you can learn more
about the center for entrepreneurial
uh studies okay um
the next question comes from reynold
um they're considering attending the
program without any sponsorship
so self-funded uh can you please share
your view
taking the mba at stanford and then
going back
to southeast asia or the region
considering the lower salary or the
economic return
so maybe you can kind of talk about how
you made that decision to go back to the
region given just the change in
uh economic factors and financial
situation
so yeah it's um i actually
i got three years out of stanford which
in three years that i
um mostly funded i think stanford
does have a strong foundation
for um sort of fellowship applications
and the rest so
um i myself was about a third
beneficiary from that
which really helped um
and when it came down to it i think each
person
is different and you know you can make
career choices based on you know a plan
of how you might how you might be able
to pay it off over time and i think the
school has a lot of resources to help
you do that
so um from that perspective you know
people might ask the touchy question you
know is it worth it or
any of those things um i think this is a
lifelong commitment
going to a school like stanford and um
one of my best friends is sitting on
this panel and you know
it that's something that i that there's
no
there's no kind of financial value for
like we will continue to help
each other grow over the next
you know up to a number of years so um
from that perspective i really value the
experience that i had
and very much money was part of
picking the next jobs that i would
pursue for the first few years after the
mba
so i appreciate that as an issue and
happy to talk about in detail
um offline thank you
just to add to uh what lesnina said you
know i think it also depends on the
location you're looking to
move back to uh so i moved straight back
to singapore with an american power
company called the aes
corporation right after business school
and you know what they offered me was uh
equivalent to what they were offering
graduates in uh in the us so i think
you know if you're if you're looking to
recruit into singapore
into hong kong uh you know sort of uh
some
of the the bigger regional hubs here uh
you know the pay is very competitive
yeah it might may be a little bit less
than
than the us and of course i'm talking
about more traditional corporate roles
or or
finance roles and so on um yeah but
you've also adjusted for taxes
uh cost of living and so on and that in
turn can also be a very attractive entry
point
into the region as a whole so coming you
know coming in
from uh from a singapore or hong kong
kind of angle
but then moving from there on i moved to
vietnam for a year and a half been in
the philippines for uh
you know nearly a decade since then um
so i think it's how you plan it out as
well
what we are seeing though is that uh
even
countries uh like the philippines now
are
increasingly more open to taking on uh
foreign talent if you're not uh
you know filipino uh and paying uh
you know very good salaries for that uh
you know external experience you're
bringing into the the country on to the
organization
thank you all right um
oh richie go ahead did you have
something oh sorry justin
i do think the on a post-task adjust
adjusted basis
singapore and hong kong might actually
be quite on par
i would say the biggest gaps would be in
startups where i think the valley would
you can't get the valley like salaries
in southeast asia especially
if you've got indonesia or the
philippines but i do think like
for me for example part of the location
was really the outsides the empathy
could have on the region that
that is just beginning to to you know
take off and if you can find a way to
position yourself to capture some of
that economic upside then
that makes up for sort of the near-term
salary bumps
great thank you so much for adding that
yes and
i'd like to also add sure
yeah so so from the perspective of the
salary i may not be the best person to
to answer this because
i was fully funded by the corporation
however i would like to second everyone
adding the cost of living in this region
as well
that is actually much much lower and
even though with the
slightly lower salary that everyone has
already mentioned um
the payback period is actually not so
far different from
what you would have uh gotten from
living in the u.s
so i think uh it also has a
different pros and cons you know
if you get a maybe a slightly lower
um or more break-even timeline
you may experience like higher growth
you know and more dynamics
uh in certain industry that you join
um so i think um you know
especially especially at the gsp you
know
we are also taught to to balance uh the
money with also the interesting
motivation
uh so i think it also depends on you on
how you would
find that balance too so yeah
thanks so much i appreciate that and you
all have uh
interjected a little bit on that so
that's helpful
um another question that uh has come up
uh
popular in the chat is um
how did you approach the career so
search post mba in regards to
opportunities within
and outside of the us and i think if i
can just have one or two folks who can
address that question and then we can
move on
uh i'd love to take that because i did a
uh i would say sort of a self search
in a sense um and i would say
you know leveraging the alumni network
is just so invaluable
and the thing about the gsb is while
the class size might be a lot smaller
than uh some of
our uh you know well-known peers in
the east coast uh which also leads to a
small
alumni community globally uh the bonds
are so much tighter
and you know within you you reach out to
pretty much
any alum uh you know even those who are
extremely senior like
could be the the president of a
corporation for asia pacific for example
and typically you'd get a a reply back
within 48 hours
you know and they'd be very willing to
help to have a chat
um so i personally leveraged that angle
uh you know had introductions uh through
uh
student friends at the time and then
also through
uh alumni and um i think that's been a
very valuable resource
for especially opportunities outside of
the us
uh this is lazina i think i knew
pretty pretty early on that i was
probably going to
look internationally as well and i think
something that was
really helpful was the flexibility the
gsb had for extensive
um sort of internship experiences
whether it's
during the school year during the
summers things like the gmax
and um sort of just the internship times
i was able to do internships both in the
us during the school year
um tied to classes i was able to do an
independent study which was linked to an
um sort of a six-month internship in san
francisco
i had two internships
during both summers i had these were
critical experiences for me
too especially for someone who's looking
to branch out of you know
core investment banking to explore and
really experience different
opportunities
um and the gsb does a great job of
you know especially through the gmx and
others providing that network
as nish was saying of of potential
sort of alumni who are willing to
respond to you as well as just
you know the the experiences that are
built into the program
so i'd really leverage that
i like how you both highlighted that
well our
um the size of the alumni community
might be
less than some of the peer institutions
uh the tight-knit collaborative culture
is second to none so uh you know
it's it's really one of those things in
terms of
identifying who are really invested in
you
and i've heard time and time and again
that uh
the response that people get from our
alumni community
is just bar none in terms of really
reaching out and being available
so i think that's one of the great and
unique aspects
of the gsb which makes us so special
all right um i'm gonna move on to
another question
uh from mayank he is asking as an
international
student what factors did you consider
in choosing the stanford gsb for your
mba program
and did the experience meet your
expectations
so if you can think a little bit about
what it was that maybe
drew you to the program relative to
other schools
i don't want to harp on the same point
but the fact that it was smaller
really was a big plus for me because
i mean i know myself from that
perspective i thrive in smaller
communities and
and just i knew from hearsay from
understanding the network
that that the alumni were um
were very responsive and i knew that
that was
that's also what you're what you're
going into this for
to develop that broader community
thanks i think two things for me
uh and you know
these days uh there's a lot of focus on
on rankings and things like that and
people tend to get very caught up in
these things but
i think there's something to be said for
brand um you know and i think the
stanford brand in
uh the global business context is is
really
uh second to none um and then
that couple with the school's sort of
genuine focus on on social and
environmental
uh innovation at the time i applied uh
you know i'm sure at this point as well
uh was also something that i think
really spoke to me uh so there's really
this uh
deeper purpose that people tend to
pursue
right this is uh the social mission in a
sense
uh and that can be implemented through
through business through startups
you know doesn't necessarily mean you
need to work for a non-profit in in
cambodia for example um and and that
traces right back to the application
question
what matters most to you and why you
know i mean stanford really wants to
understand what makes you tick um and
so i think that's something that really
spoke to me during the application
process
thank you yeah as for me
at that time i was actually looking for
uh
alternatives or ways to improve my
leadership ability
and uh it boils down to two kind of
routes
whether to continue working in the
management role for a few more years
or to find some sort of leadership camp
and you know after attending
a session like this and talking to a
bunch of
alumni uh who who went to stanford gsp i
know it was
uh the right choice uh particularly
because of the
uh the experience the focus on the
experiential learning
that stanford gsb provides
um for example i think some of uh some
of our panels are has already mentioned
about the mge class where we role play
with
the professors on the difficult
situations
and that actually does bring
not only the experience
portion but also the feedbacks that you
would get from your classmates
on how you would deal with this type of
difficult
for these situations also i think beau
mentioned about the
leadership lab you know where we get uh
film and you know kind of get go back
and observe
how we negotiate or discuss
on topics with our classmates and that
actually
brings life to me in terms of leadership
development as well because sometimes
you would think of yourself in certain
things
but when you watch the video you realize
that there's a gap
and that's when you have the light bulb
that
you know what you need to improve in
terms of leadership
development and definitely i think
my experience exceed the expectation
before i join
so uh it is probably the best investment
i
i had in in term of education
for me thank you
all right i'm going to turn to another
question um i think
you can definitely add to this but i
encourage anyone else to
respond as well um just because i know
you mentioned it in your intro
so one of the candidates on here is
asking a question
regarding um the global experience
so during your time at the gsb what
global coursework did you find useful
for your experiences now that you're in
southeast asia or did you use your
global experience whether it was the
global seminars the gmix the study trips
um in southeast asia or did you explore
another part of the world so maybe you
can talk a little bit about what the
expectations are around that too
sure i think uh in this especially in
this
uh era i think uh
most of us would agree that you know
having an experience in the global
context would help
in term of doing business or even
non-profit social enterprise
uh so what i did what was that i
actually chose
the areas that i have very minimal
experience in
for example like mexico you know it's
kind of like a foreign
very foreign territory for me
you know uh the food is different from
and
uh i chose japan as well because
japan even though it's in asia it still
has this kind of
uniqueness about them in doing business
and the culture even the culture of
doing business
it's different in terms of they might
have more uh seniority
uh you have to always kind of listen to
your boss so
that kind of things and also like
another one that the internship that i
did was in jordan
also provides me with very valuable
experience in terms of how to
negotiate with people from from from
that region that i might not have much
experience before the gsp
so um all this experience that uh
kind of come with the global experience
requirement
actually makes me a more um
i guess i would say whole in as a
now uh an mna
lead for international business for pdt
which is the thai national energy
company
so um yeah i hope that answers the
questions
yeah great i like to add on that
so i did a lot of um this international
requirement as well um so i did the
the g mix um in mexico city and also did
uh two study trips
um to um iceland and and sweden
and also another one in india and also
um
i was also a co-president of stanford
qinghua
exchange program which takes place
around
thanksgiving time um so for this program
actually you just work with a
peer from like your peers from from
qinghua on on a project
and then you um go to china for
two weeks and then they also come to the
bay area for two weeks as well so you
get to know more people in china and
they got to know
their perspective and also working on
the project
which is um china focused so that's
that's really helpful
and also um did an internship in in
south korea in samsung
so all this i think um i i feel like
i have um graduated from being like a
just a thai citizen into a global
citizen because i embrace so much of the
international mindset
and feel like i know how to react in
each situation
when i'm in a um whatever region
whatever region i feel
i can get along with them and trying to
understand
that perspective and act accordingly i
think this is really important because
after
the gsb i also did a lot of
international
transactions and have to deal with
people from
around the world i think um kind of from
assessing
assisting myself it really makes
a big difference on that
thank you um i want to pose a question
uh to richie about um
career pivoting uh since i believe
that's something that you did is there
anything you can share
with the audience about how like either
career work resources you use
to make that happen for you yeah
quite a lot uh i go to the career office
sort of once a month just to like sort
of sort of
helped my help help myself figure out
what i wanted to do and so i think
gsb offers a lot of resources from
career exploration to just
figuring out what what in the world you
want to do and then interviewing and
prepping for it so
i do think from the end to end i've
utilized that quite well and the people
from the cmc will
attest to it but beyond that they the
alumni network that they uh that the gsp
has and
i do think there's there are mentoring
networks available we have databases
that you can look up alumni and i think
those are the best ways i've found
that have been quite helpful for me and
instead of getting up to speed with the
industry that i want to pivot into
okay great thank you
um i'm going to take a couple more
questions
uh and then i'll turn it back over
uh we generally go 45 minutes past
we're doing a little bit longer today
but if any of you have to jump off
please just let me know and feel free to
do so when we get to the 45 minute mark
um can can you all kind of talk about or
at least a couple of you
the what that alumni community looks
like in southeast asia and what people
might
be expected to have available to them
after uh returning from the gsb or
uh yes i can tell
uh thailand you know i think i also echo
was definitely
mentioned earlier that is all about
quality over quantity
uh we do have a smaller alumni uh you
know due to the smaller class size of
stanford
some people might see that as a weakness
however i think
it could actually be the strength
because
it makes the alumni community much more
tight-knit
and when you know someone uh at a
deeper level it means that they are also
more invested
in each other as well so i think in
terms of alumni quality in thailand you
know we have
all people come back and you know
spread across different industries tech
energy
education um so so i think i found that
very
very useful um so and and very helpful
i am very helpful for for my career uh
advice or career search so i think
um that tight-knit uh community the tiny
alumni community
uh does uh play play an important role
for my career
thank you yeah
oh sorry you go first richie oh yeah
sorry echoing that i i do think
like every mentor i've had you know a
lot of gsb years from from many many
different years and
decades even really take time to mentor
me and that
that's really proof of you know how deep
the relationships go i i've known this
for three years now and we've kept in
touch
uh ever since and i think that's an
attestment to how
how just strong and tight your of the
network will have once you sort of get
into the gsb
yes yeah i could just add a philippine
perspective you know i think the
the stanford uh community in the
philippines is very tight very vibrant
and uh not just with respect to the gsb
but
uh you know more broadly across
different schools
um it's probably a couple of hundred
alums but in terms of those who are
probably most the most active maybe
about 30 to 40
uh but uh you know we've got our own
viber group going we've got our mailing
list there's events um
hell at least once every quarter um
and everyone is extremely supportive and
so that camaraderie that you you build
on uh in school or definitely translates
to
the alumni network like if you meet any
alum anywhere in the world and you feel
the sense of um
kinship right almost like you're meeting
family and i think that's um
something that's really uh very
difficult to quantify
when you're thinking about investing in
a degree at the gsb
um from a quick regional perspective um
the indonesia the indonesia alumni
community is pretty
um it's pretty small but as niche said
um
we also have our own sort of expanded
mailing list which is pretty active to
be honest
on whatsapp um talking about you know
it's just very much about sharing
information
um and everyone's kind of looking to
just we have pretty
interesting debates and and because of
the you know the origin or the the
context for some of us it's like we have
debates about
you know the power sector policies here
transport etc
it's it's pretty fun um
from that perspective i also want to
highlight that singapore serves as a
regional hub
so they actually have a number of
events every every month
and i mean it previously it was you know
if you're flying through singapore you
can anyone can kind of just
you know attend and sign up and now it's
like they're doing a little bit more
webinar style etc but
it's still a huge resource for us an
ability for us to connect across the
region
great thank you um
one more question that caught my eye
that i thought was interesting i'd love
to hear some of your perspectives
with so many amazing classmates did you
ever experience impostor syndrome and if
so how did you
cope
i think we're probably still
experiencing it
all the time
you know our dean our former dean used
to say at the intro
orientation to all incoming first-year
students that
uh you know look to your left and your
right and you'll say to yourself
how did i get in right all these amazing
people next to you
and and then would say by the end of
this year you'll look to your left or
your right
and you'll say how did these people get
in so there's a little bit of a mindset
shift that might happen
too but yes you are surrounded by
some incredible classmates um
but also very humble i think one of the
things that's so wonderful about the
community is that you
you learn and grow from one another and
you're open to that
i i will say that yeah
[Music]
as an international student your you
know a lot of the class
uh points out the marks you get are
based on class participation right i
mean you're
really learning so much from uh just
debates and discussions in the classroom
with your
uh with your classmates with the
professor and it may
especially given an asian or even uh to
some extent
australian uh perspective not be as
natural to stick your hand up and say
hey you know i'd like to push back on
that point that you just said lazina
right
uh when when you're uh coming from an
international background whereas you
know a lot of the americans many of whom
went to
uh liberal arts colleges have been sort
of debating and critiquing and engaging
in these kind of
um approaches for for years right even
since uh
since high school so i think that is
something that initially you
feel a little bit out of your debt but i
think
very fast you're pushed to kind of
contribute and stick your hand up and be
more assertive and
i thought that was a very valuable part
of personal development at the gasb
and just coming out a more confident
assertive person
yeah i definitely think in that and and
also
you know i actually did fail that
impostor syndrome a little bit
you know who would not write because you
would be surrounded by
for example my classmate he was an
engineer at nasa who built this
uh robot that landed on mars and that's
a guy who
you know built his own startup sold it
for several hundred million
dollars before he joined dsp
uh he for like five or six years before
he joined the gst for example
uh but after going there you know and
get to meet them they're all
super nice people and i come to realize
that it's actually the gsp is actually
kind of like the avengers
you know sorry about the the
um superhero comparison but
you know if in in avengers right you
would find someone like captain america
uh would be really good and have really
good leadership
but another guy who like for example
like hawkeye
he'll be really good at using arrows so
i come to realize that everyone has
their own strengths
and that actually brings the depth of
discussion or learning
to the community um so they're good at
their own things you know they're good
at their own
expertise and and that's what is so
beautiful about about going to the
place like the gsp for me
great thank you all right i'm looking at
the clock we've got about
five minutes left and one of the
questions i always like to
end with has also come up in uh the q a
by a couple of folks and really relates
to this
um theme around you know if you could go
back
and speak to yourself um as you were
applying to this
stanford um what advice would you give
or in general just what advice might you
give your pre
gsb self so if each of you want to just
uh give a couple of blurbs i'll start
with lizena
not to put you on the spot but if you
can think of something uh and then i'll
go around to the rest of the group and
just get your thoughts
um you know nish mentioned the fact that
the essay
um you know what matters most to you and
why i think i
i was like emotionally traumatized
trying to like
get the right answer to that and try to
figure out what the right answer would
be and then eventually
the right answer is whatever really
authentically matters to you and just
um you know advice i would give to
myself is just like trust your
instincts trust what you care about and
like
i guess one of the anthems of the gsp is
kind of like lead with your heart
right you just have to be out there and
um
authentic and that's what's going to get
you the truest answer
thank you i'm going to hand it over to
nish hopefully you had some chance to
think about it
yeah so you know i actually very happy
with the
my gsb experience and the time i spent
there i think a priority for me coming
in was really getting to know
our classmates in the years above the
years below because
it tends to otherwise be quite a a
bubble right you're
surrounded by classmates in your year uh
so i was involved with a lot of
extracurricular stuff you know
gsb show and seeing uh gsb unplugged
which
these are the the flagship sort of uh
campus and theater events uh you know
extracurricular clubs
uh the nhg club uh
admit weekend and so on but i you know
looking back now i think the one
area where that uh philosophy could have
been extended a bit was maybe
taking a a class or two across the
street as they say at stanford uh
specifically the design school because i
think
the design thinking is just such a
different way of approaching problems
versus um
the more business uh foundation that we
have
um and i think it's something to be
uh cognizant of that when you go to the
gsb you go to stanford you're not just
going to a great business school you're
going to an institution that's um
amongst the top in the world for every
field you know so try to
while things are very busy try to maybe
carve out a little bit of time to to
make
most of uh one or two of the
opportunities uh in in other schools uh
on campus thank you thank you richie do
you wanna head out yeah
sure i can do it uh i i would say like
looking back after the
busy two years i've had and i was
telling someone that
it's been much easier than my finance
days but i would have
lived more deliberately with the way i
used to spend my time the gsb
in terms of the friendships i fostered
and the activities i've taken
um part of it is when you come into the
gsb you think you have to do every
single thing in front of you and there's
just not enough time to do it and
that's when sort of to get stressed out
because how do you
do all these amazing things and meet all
these amazing people but
i think the most value i've gotten was
you know the handful of friends have
really fostered very meaningful
friendships that i've had
i know will last me you know beyond the
gsb and many many decades to come
and i think that's really the most
important thing is is
know like what you want out of the
experience and just go for it when
you're there
thank you all right i'll jump over to bo
if you can
share something i would encourage richie
um i think like to everyone prioritizing
is the key here
because going to business school is like
drinking from a fire hose
like you like it's so mouthful like
you kind of like each day just go by
without you noticing like there's so
many things to do like
social academics um you have to foster
friendship with your friends and they're
all clubs and activities
so uh prioritizing is a key i feel like
um
i always compare um going to the gsb as
um
like going shopping in a department
store like you have
so many there's so many things like
whatever you want
is there but you just have to know what
you want and go there and get it
otherwise you're going to be like
so overwhelmed and and this is how you
you can maximize your experience by
knowing exactly what you want okay thank
you
and we'll round out with you ateep we
started with you and
let's
[Laughter]
sure actually i'll also echo with
all the panels today and especially
on the last question uh regarding
the uh you know because the gsb
is such a wonderful place you know
anything that you would like to learn
more you would probably be able to
to learn more and that's actually a term
that i remember in the first year called
fomo
or fear of missing out i think many of
the freshmen
has experienced that partly because they
want to
to kind of get almost 100 of everything
that is on
offered by the dsp uh i was one of that
for that student and uh looking back
probably
if i were doing if i were to do a little
bit more research about what were to
offer
at the gsb uh or were to offer
at stanford university as a whole i
might be able to
prioritize that uh better and also
probably
be more focused on what i really needed
for my career aspiration so
just to summarize it up you know for
that is that
i think everyone has their own strengths
and they know already
what they want to improve so
if they find out and with what gsb has
to offer then you
they will probably have a very cool
experience
uh in in for two years
right i just want to end on is we do
have a cornerstone on one of our
buildings at the gsb
which states the following dedicated
to the things that haven't happened yet
and the people
who are about to dream them up dream
them
up and i hope today that you got excited
about what the gsb has to offer for you
i also want to thank you all for
taking the time to be here if
you have any questions feel free to
reach out to us we would love to connect
with you there are many other ways in
which you can get engaged with the
community
through our information sessions panels
like what you hope
that we saw today we also host them for
diversity and women's and other regions
so we encourage you to take advantage of
that
and thank you all again today for your
time
and to all of the panelists that are
here thank you so much
for sharing some time in your day
i certainly appreciate it and i'm sure
many of the folks online today did as
well
so have a great morning or
evening wherever you happen to be in the
world
i all the best everyone
yeah thank you it's my pleasure as well
thank you